i'll tell you the one thing the only
thing that matters is that sean penn
flees to poland on foot after calling on
america to fight for ukraine why
like
this is this is this beat the game
he was very anti-war wasn't he in the
early 2000s was that huge part of his
chick in his activism
i'm just exhausted by this sean penn i
don't know or care about you and why are
you telling us to get involved in a war
with russia which is a nuclear power
this is the stupidest thing ever
like we this is this actor guy goes to a
foreign country during a war and then
he's like we got to go fight for them no
no we don't and you shouldn't have been
there
i just
you know i will say this americans are
certainly arrogant that's for sure
and um
yeah maybe most of them
you know in different ways
we have this contingent of the hollywood
establishment elites and the democrat
elites and they're just they're so full
of themselves they're so entitled and
then you also have you know many other
americans and maybe more justified in
arrogance you know in the observation of
american power and might around the
world i was just watching a howard stern
clip of uh what's his name from breaking
bad the guy odenkirk and he was like oh
and after you know before he got
breaking bad it was so hard i was
writing and we were barely making any
money and i had to this big loan and and
stern was like oh that must have been so
hard for you
like he was like you know i'm trying i'm
writing movies and taking these little
acting roles and i'm in debt and
stern's reaction that he must what
suffering you must have been going
through having to write movies and act
and being dead i'm like what how
detached these people have become for
what real suffering is yeah yeah
this um this kind of reminds me of uh
the peaceful protests and how a lot of
people were acting really irrationally
like that mass psychosis where now you
got a bunch of people that are openly
just hating
russians because they're trying to like
shut off cars and stop selling their
products and stuff like that it's like
you're you're demonizing an entire
population of people in the same way
that people were so willing to go smash
businesses and and hurt people that
weren't putting their fist up in the air
just because they thought that they were
actually doing something helpful
well in some instances they actually are
vandalizing russian owned businesses or
companies with the word russia in the
name like this happened in canada it
happened in germany it's insane like
this is the beautiful ones dude this is
yeah okay so let me go back to the rat
utopia yeah yeah in the rat utopia they
put all these rats in a big box they
gave them all the food and water they
wanted and then left them alone and
eventually a group developed called the
beautiful ones in the behavioral sink
these are people who did nothing but
groomed themselves
they just groomed themselves and tried
to make themselves more beautiful and
that's the virtue signal that's what
we're seeing now with people like sean
penn look at this tweet from him
myself and two colleagues walked miles
to the polish board after abandoning our
car on the side of the road almost all
of the cars in this photo carry women
and children only most without any sign
of luggage and a car their only
possession of value and here is like
they stay they planned this photo of him
walking
this is
sean penn's
vapid
ego
virtue signal on display
his intentions as i this is my opinion
of him is that he wants his name to
matter he wants to be beautiful and seen
by everyone so he flies himself into a
war zone and then makes it about him and
what he's doing and we must fight what
are you doing there this guy has nothing
to do with this no experience here but
he wants people to see him as
beautiful i'm getting tropic thunder
vibes yeah yeah some of that last night
but this but this is virtue signal to
the to the uh nth degree to the to the
like
you could not virtue signal more than
flying into a war zone and then being
like we abandoned our cars fleet on foot
because only women and shut up if it was
like why don't you put the damn camera
down and help if it's actually
you know this is a photo shoot to me
this is virtue signaling because the in
the behavioral sync the rats or the mice
whichever because they did both just
wanted to look beautiful
well beautiful to rats is just
you know grooming yourself and then
having other rats look at you
for for a a male it is it is peacocking
it is
making yourself as boisterous and loud
and visible as possible
this to me is the epitome of
self-grooming behavioral sync
a guy with no business in this war
flies in
films himself going there
post social media of like look what i'm
doing
and it's just like
we've gotten to the point now where we
have these plastic robot people
they treat all of this like a game like
a tv show
this is the most insane thing
you know it's just like
he just wants people to see him and he
wants to say i went to ukraine during
the war
i talked to the families the us must
fight like shut up shut your mouth go
home you pathetic loser oh who's that
care what you have to say about this you
have nothing to do with it jane fonda
went to vietnam i think and hung out
with the viet cong is that what it was
man the media launched on her for trying
it was basically like if someone was
went to russia right now and was trying
to like show some humanity about the
russian people jane fonda did that in
vietnam but they did not people did not
want that
i think this guy's an actor you know
i've always got the vibe from sean penn
that he really wants to help people and
but and so kind of that's kind of what i
was going through as a kid and i thought
let me go into acting so that i can be
famous and then when i tell people like
good ideas that i have i'll be able to
tell them to more people and i think
that's
i've always thought sean penn was a
pretty ethical guy but when you're an
actor that's all you really know how to
do is act you just talk in front of a
camera that's his job it's what he's
done his whole life i don't i've never
seen any other skills this guy has
yeah i think you might be right and it's
commonly said that americans have main
character syndrome and i commented on
twitter that our main import at this
point is narcissism because npr was
talking about how to maintain your
self-composure when you're reading the
news about people fleeing their homes
and being bombed and stuff and i was
like what kind of narcissism is this it
makes us think that we're the most
important people and ian is right about
sean penn being an actor this picture is
so clearly staged it's kind of
disturbing to think that people are
actually suffering and he is treating it
like a movie yeah many americans are and
they're like all this crazy stuff
happening the ghost of kiev snake island
and it's like i wonder how much of this
stuff will be proven to be false as we
go on we're just treating it like a
movie oh who are we gonna cast as
zelinski when the movie comes around
it's like jeremy renner for sure no what
is wrong with us though like why are we
thinking about that sean penn arrives in
ukraine to film documentary about
russian invasion
the actor and director came to tell the
world the truth about russia's invasion
of our country says the office of
ukraine's president imagine
imagine being as vapid as this guy is
he's bored you know man yeah
you know what man i'm just i just the
virtue signaling has just reached a
point where it's just vomitus have you
guys seen ukraine on fire the
documentary
i have not yet it's an oliver stone so
oliver went in there i think it was from
four years ago he did this this is four
years ago so oliver stone i mean he was
talking about this stuff way before any
kind of physical conflict erupted
basically about the cia coup in ukraine
and the installation of poroshenko and
basically how you uh the you know
the the u.n or whatever the heck this
body nato is pushing the borders of
russia pushing right up against the
borders of russia
uh and i have a lot of respect for
oliver stone so you want to talk about
some of the entertainment industry
that's really doing good making
documentaries about this stuff oliver
stone is is at the tip of the spear
maybe this will be end up being really
good i don't know i don't want to shoot
it flies in
meets uh goes to the president's office
to officially support them and he
condemned russia before even knowing
what's going on in the country and
that's something like not even anybody
advice would do
you know they would go in and they would
have their assumptions based on stories
they read but they wouldn't be like we
hereby declare that we're we're sending
in journalists to uncover all the lies
about the invasion they'd be like we're
sending a reporter to see what's going
on what's up yeah and that's that's
about it and then you know it was like
the crazy thing is vice as like fast and
loose as it was with a lot of its
journalism
took it seriously like uh one of the one
of our reports i remember i think glenn
beck criticized vice when i was working
there
because i think it was danny gold one of
the one of the vice reporters went to
israel went to palestine during um
i think it might have been operational
protective edge and danny also went to
israel you know he went to palestine and
israel and documented what people were
going through and glenn beck i think it
was glenn i'm sorry if i'm getting this
wrong maybe it wasn't glenn but some
conservative pundit criticized him
saying they're only showing what the
what the you know the palestinians are
going through and now the israelis are
going through and we're all confused by
that because we are like vice put out
literally two short docs showing the
palestinian and israeli sides of the
conflict and it wasn't really like
like there was it wasn't pro once out of
the others like here we are here's
what's happening
so that's the issue i take with this
because certainly you know i've had my
share of parachuting into many different
countries but we would never go in and
just you know valiantly decry and
declare we knew it was going on in fact
when i was in ukraine there was um
british media public like publicly no no
it wasn't publicly funded british media
it was one of their news corporations
had put out fake news about a protest
that was actually pro yanukovych i could
be getting this wrong it's been almost
10 years
and it was uh a big rally of ukrainians
came out to support their president and
then some media outlet like lied about
it and said it was it was opposing it or
whatever and we were all confused we
were like what they're all waving
ukrainian flags and supporting their
president
but of course the western narrative was
the ukrainians hated yanukovych and they
didn't want the russian regime they
wanted the eu and all that stuff so you
got the same fake news so when i see
like these vapid hollywood actors who
specifically fly into a country
to tell the world the russians are to
tell the truth about russia's invasion
of our country says the ukraine's uh say
office of ukraine's president and he
meets with the president and it's very
clear he has an agenda i'm like this i
just i can't stand the lies in the
propaganda like there are a lot of
journalists down there right now who are
doing a really good job and telling
people what's going on and it does not
look good for russia and that's all you
need to do you don't need to
you know who's cool trey yanks is cool
who's that fox news
trey he's uh i'm pretty sure he's on the
ground right now in kiev reporter oh
cool oh yeah
yeah he did a good job there you go
that's what a reporter does they go down
then they say here's what's happening
right like they're tweeting like air
raid sirens
like they're not posting photos of
themselves with like at an angle with
like carrying their bank i abandoned my
car we have to make it to the border
yeah they're not doing that they're like
wearing bulletproof vests like i'm
reporting here in central kiev right now
we're hearing
because there's journalism and then
there's whatever this is the beautiful
ones of universe 25. this is kony 2012
2022 remember that movie coney 2012 man
the propaganda campaign that was crazy
everywhere i didn't know what they were
it was it was
colony 2012. you guys remember you don't
remember that it was uh i remember that
there was this documentary it was it was
like a commercial and it was the
stupidest thing ever
because it was like
the digital media has allowed us to have
power like more than ever before and we
can come together and it was this big
grandiose narrative how we can all join
forces and fight for the good of
stopping this one guy in an african
nation whose trust i remember wasn't he
already dead and he like yeah he
apparently wasn't even involved anymore
he was an evil guy had child soldiers or
something but yeah he was i think he was
already dead by the time
i don't know if he was dead but he was
like he was ousted already yeah
happening but my issue was kind of like
they made this documentary that was very
grandiose about like global affairs in
the world and they're like and that's
why we need your help to stop one guy
you've probably never heard of in a
central african nation who's like a bad
guy but man on our list of bad dudes
like outback daddy was still like you
know that was isis yeah well actually
2012
people other than this one yeah it was
all let's come together it was just felt
like world economic forum propaganda
looking back on it i was still in the
obama brain fog what was his plan though
well then the guy who did it like from
the organization was like stripped nude
and started like
jumping up and down and banging on the
pavement while gripping himself if you
know what i mean
wow i remember going on
jason russell the director was that it
yeah i'm gonna look into that that
wasn't a part of the tactic
but i'm wondering here's what i'm
wondering
what if the koni 2012 video was the test
firing of a social media manipulation
tactic or weapon basically yeah can we
weaponize propaganda to direct everyone
to do one thing and they tried it out to
see what would happen because you got to
test weapons
and it was a fifth generation warfare i
was thinking about this actually because
technically
people have the data on society as in
terms of okay what do we need to do what
do we need to put in front of people's
screens in order for them to render this
type of behavior and if you think of
like all of these crazy campaigns and
social media trends over the years like
one comes to mind like that als ice
bucket challenge and stuff just just
that and and doing these different
trends you can sort of
guess where you can lead society in a
particular direction just by socially
engineering stuff like that so
technically they have enough data to
know that they can make people jump just
by doing certain things yeah the russian
propaganda campaign has been going on
since
uh 14 2015 16 when did that turn on
2015. i mean they've all everyone's
always running propaganda campaigns like
every country's got it what i'm actually
wondering is um you guys have heard of
havana syndrome yeah
no so there are people who have reported
that they'll be you know like working in
some government building and they'll
hear a hum and then all of a sudden
they'll start getting headaches and
they'll start getting blurry vision and
they get permanent like vision damage
and for a while people were just like oh
it must be some something unrelated and
people are overreacting but then the the
white house got hit by havana syndrome
really so it may be some kind of
directed energy weapon meant to cause
long-term damage to a person because
think about it this way if you're if
you're engaged in a war with a long-term
plan
you could be thinking this person could
probably be a threat cause damage to
them now so they don't last five or ten
years in this industry diminish the
amount of time they have so they're not
a threat to you in the future
that's the kind of crazy stuff we're
saying but here's what i was thinking
with russia
do you guys really believe that nuclear
weapons are the are the pinnacle of
military might these days not anymore no
way yeah well no i mean weapons of mass
destruction generally speaking but we
can also talk about biological weapons
chemical weapons no no no no not even
laser weapons i think if you know what
it is
then it's not the pinnacle of weapons
technology oh i hear you i hear you we
didn't know about nukes manhattan
project yeah there was speculation until
they got used right yep so there was a
report that came out where it was like
what could they be building some thought
it was like a death ray like a beam that
would like you know cause damage they
didn't know for sure because all of
these different areas were working on
specific things and then journalists
couldn't put it together
so
if the us
or any country has something
one of the arguments put forward is that
we would see the the infrastructure
operation you'd see the trucks bringing
certain materials to certain areas and
bringing them underground you'd know
they'd be building something but you
don't know what they'd be building so is
it cyber is it influence influential is
it psychological manipulation or is it
possible that like we we even understand
the concept of rods from god that's the
giant saddle satellite holding giant
tungsten rods it drops them and they
slam into the earth they're like more
powerful than nukes
could they have something more powerful
than even that i think because they
wouldn't tell us i think that tiny tiny
micro drones that can fly into people's
ears are pretty dangerous
i'm not i don't know about that i know i
don't either that's the problem but
that's a good idea because it's in your
ear tim that's why you don't know
that's a good point right like i'm so
ready to dismiss the idea of micro
drones flying in your ear and like
killing you or whatever but that's
actually a a good idea we would not know
and we would think it was crazy if like
a cia officer was just like the u.s
micro drones flying here kill you like
that we'd be like shut up
not true because we wouldn't believe it
i remember i think it was 2004 i was
like they can fly a drone into a window
and hurt someone like it was like
groundbreaking the concept of being able
to literally like
i don't know if you guys remember the
black mirror episode but the way they
introduce these tiny lethal drones was
because the bees died i was like oh well
we have bees that are dying that's so
interesting what if we decide to try to
fix this problem with these little
drones that can activate if your social
credit score is low or something like
that and that's what ended up happening
in that episode thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you